Je me souviens vraiment que la toute dernière scène de
la scène était la scène où Jeff
et Bella avaient leur troisième danse au
mariage et
se disaient en quelque sorte au revoir et je veux dire
que c'était une scène émouvante pour le
personnages et c'était aussi ma
dernière chose dans la franchise, donc je veux dire que je
me souviens que très précisément je devais
porter un clochard mais euh que les prothèses
avaient besoin d'être aidées comme elles ont fait
une forme sur mon visage en gros, il
fallait alors être  numériquement réduit donc j'avais le
syndrome de la grosse tête maigre je
veux dire parce que c'était comme si vous deviez mettre du
volume mais c'était la forme du visage d'une
personne maigre vraiment pas mignonne
je suis si heureuse que ça soit allé si loin
les gens adorent éviter les choses dans les
films à grand profil et l'ensemble des points
dans ce film est qu'elle parle depuis
quatre films trois films sur la façon dont elle est
prête à mourir pour cela et maintenant vous la
voyez vraiment la voir se rapprocher en
regardant Taylor et imprimer o  n bébé
c'était très très amusant que j'ai gardé et
aussi juste voir Taylor avec son
look oh j'ai hâte de faire la première des
prochaines femmes américaines j'ai eu tellement de
blagues que je peux en faire ses frais donc
ça va être très amusant  le jour où
j'imprimais un X sur le mur, j'ai donc
dû littéralement marcher dans la pièce,
regarder ce X et l'imprimer, c'était donc
un défi ce jour-là, mais je suis vraiment
très content de la façon dont il s'est avéré que
je  J'ai vraiment apprécié le processus de travail
avec les factures, donc vous savez, je suppose que je
pourrais m'amuser comme vous le savez, j'ai vu des
moments de spoiler que j'aimais ou quoi, mais
travailler avec Bill Condon était vraiment un
honneur, il y a définitivement un moment où
c'est comme si vous étiez le nouveau  professeur dans la
salle de classe et vous avez un genre vous savez
gagner les gens mais je dois dire que les
acteurs étaient incroyablement accueillants J'ai
vraiment apprécié la scène avec Kristen
où j'ai dû lui annoncer la nouvelle vous
savez qu'elle ne peut pas avoir ça  bébé
parce que ça va la détruire je veux dire
pas en  joyeux dans le sens où c'était une
scène amusante mais c'était une scène très émouvante
et et je pensais que
Kristen sortait vraiment du stade sur le fait qu'elle l'
écrasait de l'intérieur ouais nous
abandonnerons avant que vous ne puissiez livrer l'un de mes
préférés  les souvenirs étaient la scène de danse
que la fête de mariage, je pensais que
c'était tellement amusant et c'est juste que
nous étions tellement heureux que c'était au milieu
que je pense qu'il était environ 6h00 du
matin en fait nous avons tourné toute la
nuit ouais  et Peter a même essayé d'
injecter certains de ses propres mouvements de danse
dans la scène sans me le dire ni à
Bill Cosby et nous avons dû faire une autre prise
mais c'était toujours amusant sur le moment ouais d'
accord mesdames et messieurs merci
beaucoup c'est  une pause photo Oh